This is the Cal N.E.H. American English dialect recordings
collection tape number eighteen. I'd
be.
In
grade school were or were outside. You mean both in school and out of school
or. Well I don't want to have a lot of fun with Again we call pum
pum pull away.
Remember that. Let's see it's one of
these games that was played where kids would line up on one side of a
yard or street. And
a youngster in the center
with say pum pum pull away get your heart and run away and he says that there when we have to run away
to yell a fag and this kid was tag someone and we tag
and then that person would have to stay in the center
street and you can see if he went on more and I would get into the Senate
Athena become more and more difficult for those on the other side to get across and so this
was one of them and use the round up with one person who was laughing who won.
And
I
know that when America enjoyed
some
nice.
Oh hi and see. Yeah. Yeah we've
debated.
How did we do that it seems to me that we.
I don't know whether we want to be it the first time. Or not and because it seems that
I can remember I mean I mean I mean no I mean it and this sort of thing with
the African hindsight I wish I could tell you but I've forgotten.
I mean one of Paul's strong you know how you can
you. Yes
the training we had many of it I can remember you mean
doing it.
Thank you.
I got up to let them in China I think. I when
I went on there was you know one hit with a rolling pin
and. I remember that part of it but I can't remember the beginning of it.
Yeah yeah.
Well we had our friend named we had boulders.
We had. McGregor marbles. Went off and we
have had several expressions in
expression hunching I guess I've caught on to the something where. If you
push the model when you see I would call it hunting I guess what you just.
Expressing I don't know what it is
now. About my will.
Yeah I can't recall no other than they had boulders we
had if the ad gets to is another name that we call it
or had.
I just. Always turns out in the back online thinking.
How do we call that. That wasn't the boulder.
Ball is a big and.
I can recall a rather special name that I can
recall.
I marveled. It is game duck on the rock which is
with tin cans in the alley.
And I'm sure I would put. Wood for the brick in the center of
the alley
and one kid I guess who was it again put
his can on
the stone brick then.
Oh
everyone. I'm trying to think of how it started it didn't start
that
way and oh we had with your life a chalk line or some kind of line
and we stood back and everyone had a sort of a can store this right now the one who is
the farthest away from the land things the one I was five years away would be the one
who scan had to go on the rock. Stand and write the rest on.
No no it was a lie it was a rock in the Senate alley and everyone had to throw
their canst toward this rock right that can that was I guess
a father's away from the rock was the one that was
it and he had it coming because his can on the rock mean everyone stood over the
can right now you had to lean over and pick up you can thought not the thought of
a can also rock without him the thing you pick up you can.
And if he's. If he saw you.
I don't know where they chased you. Or not or hit you
or try to reach your what it was that you try to not use can alter the
Rock and what the objective what I've forgotten now but we've had a lot of
fun playing you know.
That's right yeah you try not to can often if you.
If you knock it off then he'd have
to run and get it and put it back in the meantime get put it back on.
Before he could take you.
He couldn't tag anyone with can Arthur Rock that was away as a prize. And
I can't remember all
the particulars but we have a lot of
fun.
What a family is this for many of them and some of their
past in color
you know they care for you know.
We've
spent a lot of our time with a lot of hobbies to get us not only games right know.
This make a lot of model airplanes fly and make them fly and break and we went through a
stage where you just model airplane crazy or.
Underground Bronx with
the hole in the ground one time six feet deep. I guess fix
the ride and then put it was in a field and
put shot it all up put the ground back put all the grass and everything
back and had a start down there with a pipe. Coming up products
then this is actually dangerous so because it was when he told. All
stoves we put on a guy with
a pipe up from the ground it was the only thing coming up from the ground when the lady across
the street found out about it and he may call the police and may discover
that up but the underground bunker and then we
read about the Wright brothers what time we were going to make the glider jump
off the grass can fly it
because I felt the wrong brother.
And we got in an argument as to who was going to fly and
I guess it was a good thing we did it never got off the ground although we do a lot of plans we're going to cover it make
it out of bamboo and cover it with canvas and
whatnot.
And I guess. Huntley Brinkley will be one of
nine. Scope ever a net Viet-Nam series right
now called.
Not
too much for some of the more popular programs.
Yeah
this is what I mostly it's Lugard can a fifty sport on channel
fifty fifty and what I do.
And I think it's terrific. I think they give insight into
the Vietnam problem it's pretty hard to get otherwise I mean they're presenting pro and
con and.
I think it's a tremendous series only thing I think most people it's
I think it comes on at the same time the other probably more popular programs.
Come on that people ought to be seeing a don't see and consequently when the issue comes up they react
on emotional basis rather than
a rational basis.
I think it's. It's one of
these things were. Persons who are familiar with the
communist doctrine and its tenets. Are going
to be beguiled by the fact they're saying that this is
an internal revolution it's
not one it's. One of the ration so-called.
Crawford by the theory that Martin Tung has put forth. He
is not a tight knit that he made a mistake in career in using
the traditional type of invasion to foster a
communist doctrine so iffy. And so he developed this. Theory
of guerrilla warfare which he says
will fix. In. In bringing about the tenets of communism.
And
so is out to prove this and fast that now this is a critical thing
if it's successful there then it can be excess for many other parts of
the world
and well. So the success that the United States is on the right track
as far as I'm concerned I get arguments from all kinds of quarters as soon as
people in other parts of the world found
out that the United States was going to stick up for a small country and
it wasn't lip service and that it wasn't a paper tiger you saw what happened in Indonesia
you saw what happened. The Communist Party was from now completely seen what happened after
the number of countries are bad because you have
seen. The Dominican Republic United States had to move in
there at the time.
Dearest. Regardless of what persons would say about well it's none of our business it is
I've been someone considered the tenets of communism as a written back
in the middle of the last
century and as. Many people. Brave in
her dedicated to now the question is are we dedicated to the principles we believe in in our country.
Many of us aren't in. So it's kind of hard for us
to
you know I
don't know I'm sorry I answered you two thousand years thing do I
think
America. No
no I don't think so I think you give lip service to it in.
By and large I don't
think they really understand it let's put it this way the average American going
overseas to a foreign country. If he becomes involved in an argument with
a communist knows what he's writing about the average American does not know what he's arguing about
and yet. It shouldn't be that way because
as the principles upon which our society is based are such that he should.
To be on the
defensive when I can with a candidate but unfortunately too many on their say aren't watching programs
like scope and some of these other things it would give them the in-depth understanding of
and
reading more than just the fact that Americans are dropping bombs
on poor defenseless
people so to speak. It won't read the important story here.
So.
Anything that I could do.
Yes. I want to model airplane how to get
it while I went around thread collecting the pop bottles at that time we
were there were deposits on the bottle. I go around I'd find as many
of them as I couldn't turn a man and get the money
and buy my way airplane and.
Oh
yes but. Trying to remember things I had all kinds
of little things.
Yeah dried out no break it
and the one the in it had the tip on it was
the lucky one YOU MAKE A WISH YOU HAVE TO wish I
were you couldn't tell anyone what you are wishing for.
Rich
I started shooting star. You know you see a shooting star
make awaken or had to be silent that. Also there were
some insects
I think which ones I don't know
some kind of insect. Yeah.
But it don't appeal. Well really
fairy godmother would come and leave a little coin
there.
I think my grade school was unique compared to the one day I went to Wingard here in Detroit
is over on the boulevard with Grand Boulevard
and more and.
When I studied you here reading writing arithmetic. I think you
using phonetics at that time.
Me. We had there a manual
training shop it was called which we learn to use all kinds of tools which
later became prove useful to me or you know how to lot and I've done.
I think our education there with me at that time. At that.
And I generally was in the center I guess of the class we set an alphabetical order in my name
in Jefferson about the middle of the alphabet so that pretty well put me in center
sized thing. About all I saw was the teacher the blackboard.
And there was a flag.
And
probably the government that went on in which I was part of it.
Now
these were regular students benches chair the com desk. That
let up you know if we partly. Inkwells and in a
holding
pattern.
If I walked outside my classroom where would I be well we walked in
line and we went from class to class in line for the vest I'd be in the hall if that
if you want to. Cantor
Yeah.
Her grass and close it along the hall in
which there were exhibits and different things that I never in lockers all along the walls everywhere.
Like a water fountains strategically
located so that you could but you couldn't you had half a mission to get a drink of
water when moving from class to
class. What
was. Well your
playground
and your No one lives the shrubbery
and some at that time.
No no.
I couldn't understand this I don't think they had any swings during the regular school
year but they were put on there during the summer.
This is the reverse.
I may be wrong no no there were swings. There
were there were swings that was about all the lights me but no nothing
else. And it was a small playground they played ball and I guess they were thinking in those
terms
too. Well.
When home of course had dinner and walk home plate all the way home. So the
speak but after we got
home it was when I was all over it was a hobby as I say model airplanes
and boats and this and that but prior to that
time. We would get together
in twenty two other backyards or out me all your old broken down trucks and
things cars would drive them so the
speed.
Oh
yeah you know. I think primarily
for talking. Why is China. I can appreciate it now as I look
back here trying
to get a turn the thought going into class and also let me hear this brother someone
talking back then if it's the same individual we all know he's the head of discipline
and maybe her.
Yes as a teacher
Miss Henry. We are at me because
I make these airplane OIS is
myself. The very fact that
I had a friend tell me that after I had left there.
She had commented one time that. Oh is the frog name Rockefeller not
Iraqi Is he someone else who had said it there must be left
behind Jefferson spirit here laughter I found that this is told to me.
After me but I did
this hand as I say we were so crazy about the airplanes that all we could think
was How does someone in the we just completed the damn near a
lighted a tell me.
Now
that I'm. He
was a pleasant teaches kind of straight but he was just pleasant.
Always did like me then I can remember he seemed to take pains with
the kids and take the extra time to
explain what James wanted you to
learn and.
No one knows do analogy.
You
need specifically are you kidding
me. There is play all kinds of games on paper.
Current path around you had to my care. So I feel like Mark. This is the
idea I guess was just to keep from getting caught as it passes around
books. One time for girls
here
unequal another ten year along here a tad on this on
a side of the desk where this raw data Ryan desk is kind of
filigree and we take the I took her hair tied it was long we were here
long type of and then she was going through to get ready to move it was a horrible thing to
do but. I did.
This married. Daniel Boone. Know Daniel Boone is and they know
that Daniel
Boone Daniel Boone with you know
I'm thinking of but then you know what was his
name he was smart. I can't think this left
me but it must sound like
Bono.
I think so all we seem to teach you can't really was smart in all of his classes
and he's pretty well known the kid
you kind of liked him and her number of girls too I
can remember names and Dan
was quite right.
I think it was a clue.
There really but I can remember
going into the corner.
You know. Well. Along with
the so-called done this I guess when the boredom that went along with it because he couldn't keep
up and couldn't catch on and and so he was a nuisance and so into the corner he went
said toward the corner facing a corner.
That's about what.
I
think schools started. Eight o'clock
eight thirty maybe.
You got a three
thirty A.M. But we came home for lunch had no
intention as we left school at
twelve or eleven thirty meeting with Ben was back at twelve thirty
and I'm thinking tougher. I think that.
You have forty
five. You
know it's fifteen minutes to
twelve.
Yeah
we live on the adjacent streets. I lived on various They
lived on twenty eighth which is the next block or in and Stanford which is black or
that. Yes about my age.
No I see one frequently not frequently we
visit infrequently now and by that.
Every four or five months he'll come by here and I will buy
him.